こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
今ですねわたくし徹夜しておりまして
昨日のお昼前に起きてから
今ちょうど24時間過ぎて
今ちょうど夕方の4時くらいになろうとしております
あの
あのすごいけだるい（なんとなくだるい）です
あの最近徹夜することが多くてさ
だるくて眠くておぇーーー
ていう時があるんですけども
僕は天才的なことを考えまして
まあこのテンションで多分ね
YouTubeの動画を撮っても面白くないので
そんな徹夜明けのYouTuberにおすすめのの面白い動画を撮る方法があります
なんとYouTubeの中では
あるBGMを付けると
必ずその動画が面白くなるという禁断のBGMがあります
こちらです
（♪♪カルメン♪♪）
はい皆さん聞いたことあるのではないでしょうか
僕も昔は乱用してたんですけど
結構もうね色んなYouTuberが使ってますよ
面白い大爆笑するべき場所でこれを流しておけば
なんか皆大爆笑するだろうみたいな雰囲気だけど
実際BGMがなかったらそうでもないみたいなさ
とても乱用されるBGMでございます
でもねやっぱりこのBGMを使うと
大抵のことは何でも面白く見えるんです
これは僕の経験から言えることなんで
なので今日は
今日の動画はもう面白くないです
こんな状況でも多分そのBGMを使えば
色んなことがとても面白く見えるんじゃねぇかと思ったので
全ての動画が面白くなるという
噂を検証していたいと思います
先に言うけど
ホントになんともないことしかしないから
では行こう
うわあああビックリしたぁー
おらーーー
痛いｗ
だーれだ？